so um I'll get started title my talk
control into learning for dynamical
systems and with this sort of will
revolve around is my work at the
interplay between learning and control
particularly for robotics so with this
sort of motivated by is that if we look
at each of these robotic systems on
their own at least from a Dynamics
perspective we're pretty good at coming
up with some sort of first principles
model of each of these systems
um where sort of the complexity arises
is where these robots are operating in
different domains and under certain
conditions like icy roads and contact
and under different wind conditions and
these are the things that are difficult
to model analytically and sort of these
are the reasons why we sort of turned to
data-driven learning where we can't
write down the model by hand so we look
to data and try and figure out a model
for the system overall or at least some
addendum to the model some model we
already have
but a lot of the fundamental and sort of
naive ways you might think about doing
learning from machine learning don't
always work very well in practice when
you're talking about closed loop control
so for example naive regression where
you just minimize you know two Norm less
may work well in minimizing one step
open loop error
um but control tasks happen over long
time Horizons in closed loop so
regression what you might find is that
regression for the system and then
deploying a learn model for the system
with that was learned with naive
regression would diverge over time with
compounding errors over multiple time
steps during closed loop control so what
we need to do
at least what I argue in this talk is
that we need to orient the learning
problem around what we're ultimately
interested in which is closed loop
control or the downstream control
objective is the terminology that we use
so rather than just the model fitting
objective
so the idea should we sort of call
control oriented learning is that we
should condition the model to perform
better and be more adaptable in closed
loop right in comparison to models that
are learned naively to minimize openly
error
so today I'll discuss three different
lines of work that we've developed time
permitting to orient learning around
inclusive control the first one involved
translating the concept of
stabilizability or controllability into
algebraic conditions that we're going to
use as a regularizer for closed loop
control performance during offline
learning the second take is a little bit
different it involves structuring our
model appropriately offline in a manner
that's generally applicable but it
naturally yields a useful control
close-up controller based on lqr and
then the final work I'll talk about is
Shifting more towards the online setting
and specifically using metal learning to
learn a good extension to a nominal
model that you specify maybe through
first principles and learning an
extension to it that we can adapt well
online for adaptive control
okay
so I'll get started with the first
project which was joint work with some
folks at Google and MIT and it's going
back to this regression problem
and what we want to do is integrate some
notion of stabilizability or the ability
to stabilize the system as a constraint
with the key idea being that what this
should do is prune the hypothesis base
of functions that were were fitting over
that we're searching over and finding
one that's somehow attuned to closed
loop control
so the key question so in
stabilizability what I mean by that is
there exists a controller that as a
function of my current state where I am
where I want to be X star and ensures
that X of T my current state goes
towards
my X star of tea over time
that's what I mean by stabilizability in
the general sense
okay
the the key thing we need to sort of
overcome here is if we want to try this
out is we have to be able to describe
stabilizability algebraically to
construct an optimization problem that
we could solve to fit a model
so to do this we turn to something
called contraction Theory so if we look
at let's consider control alphine
Dynamics x dot equals f of x plus b to x
times U
um and what contraction Theory starts
off by doing is linearizing the Dynamics
but maintaining the dependence on your
linearization point so you look
everywhere State and input wise and you
look at the local linear Dynamics or the
variational Dynamics to be more specific
this is a family of linear systems and
it's an exact description of small
variations of your Dynamics near your
linearization point
and this is a linear system at least in
your variations Delta X and Delta U so
you can do is we can describe we can
construct this notion of local energy or
local distance
and this is a square distance but it's
weighted by some a metric called M of X
it's a positive definite function Matrix
function it basically generalizes the
notion of distance and allows it to
depend on your linearization point so
like I said we're sort of generalizing
notion of squared distance with some
some quantity that allows it to depend
on where you're linearizing it
um and this thing that we're waiting the
distance with is what's known as a
control contraction metric or CCM
and the idea is that we have a quadratic
uh notion of energy we have a linear
system
so anybody who's done any sort of
control theory that should scream out to
you do some sort of linear control
design that that's sort of our bread and
butter as control theorists is linear
control design with quadratic costs or
quadratic energy functions or lyopano
functions so
um the idea is that if we can design a
linear controller a local linear
controller variational controller that's
linear in the variation in x
and make and design in such a way that
this differential energy is decreasing
locally everywhere
okay
well if it's decreasing locally every
year and I integrate that differential
control Delta U between two points x and
x star so long shortest pass between x
and x star I back out another control
and what through some a lot more math
than I intend to get into in this
presentation we can show that by
integrating out control for the original
system we can get something that's
stabilizing for the original system
and it shows it makes basically makes X
of T go towards X of T So to the metric
M of X together with this energy
decrease condition which I haven't
really put any specifics on yet
um together forms a certificate for
stabilizability of our system
so we have Dynamics and we've introduced
this additional function along with some
conditions that need to have satisfied
to make the system stabilizable
so it's a
so um
without going into two any detail really
about how this is derived
the idea that there's a few things I
want to point out is that it depends on
the Dynamics
which go into now our model fitting
objective at the top
and we also have this decree condition
that ends up looking like a matrix
inequality that depends on both the
Dynamics and the well the inverse metric
okay so you've added an extra thing that
you're trying to learn
and it acts as a certificate for the
stabilizability of the thing your the
Dynamics functions that you're fitting
today
okay
um
the key problems still are those two
problems one is that the constraints are
infinite dimensional
much like a lyapanov type analysis you
want it to hold for all X
um but we can't attractively enforce
this as a constraint unless in uh other
than in some certain conditions
so what we do is we sort of relax this
and say sample some X points and turn
this into a finite number of constraints
and there's no there's no data
associated with these constraints
there's no output or labels for this
data it's I can sample as many x's in
the state spaces I want as so I can
cover the state space as densely or as
sparsely as I want
the only labels that get sort of show up
are in the actual model fitting
objective so the other intric the other
problem here is that it's non-convex you
have
Matrix inequalities that multiples of F
and W
but it's by convex so what we do to
solve this we linearly parametrize our
metric and Dynamics and alternating and
do alternating convex solves
until it converge to some local Optimum
um and so we actually did this on
Hardware with real data uh with a
quadrotor and on the left we've done
sort of naive model fitting and on the
right we've done our approach
and what we find is that
um the one on the left is not going to
do so well
it's going to start oscillating a bit
very great here
and then it starts to screw it out go to
control and ends up crashing while this
one on the right
manages to sort of track the figure
eight that it's that we've sort of
commanded it to track
and keep in mind this is sort of a quite
a remodel that sort of learned from
scratch so it's sort of it's we're not
providing any base model for it sort of
wanted to just see how well does this
method work for learning a model from
scratch
okay
um so with that I'll move into this or
the second project which sort of takes a
different spin on things
and it'll still be an offline model
learning and this was for some folks at
MIT but it sort of takes the approach
instead of trying to come up with an
addendum like an extra function an extra
certificate function
it looks at how how do we do control or
how do we build controllers for actual
physical systems well often they have
some structure to them that yields a
controller in some way so for a
mechanical system for example it has
this nice LaGrange form that for example
you could do a feedback linearizing
control on it and it depends on the you
know the second order form is specific
to yielding that controller
something that's a little more
fundamental are linear systems when we
have linear systems we have a lot of
good like I said bread and butter for
control theorists linear systems there's
a lot of theory in designing stabilizing
controllers for them specifically we can
you know specify a quadratic cost and do
lqr control which is optimal for linear
systems so it's this idea of structure
and forming control design that we're
sort of latching onto here
um it turns out that this linear like
structure can also be identified for
nonlinear systems so uh
if we have f of x plus b of x times U
again let's say that we can always
Factor this it's fundamental theorem of
calculus because Factor this as f is 0
plus a of x times x so it's some
constant offset plus all the terms in
your Taylor expansion that you can
always factor out an X from
and for such systems okay well this
looks like a linear system so we can do
you know we can solve a ricotta equation
at each feedback timestamp for each X we
encounter and do lqr like control for it
it turns out practice this has worked
pretty well and can do even better than
lqr control for nonlinear systems
um so there's a similar factorization
exists for aerodynamics for any control
affid system
the idea of being if you
write the Dynamics of X tilde dot X
tilde is x minus X star so where you are
minus where you want to go
it turns out you can factor in a similar
way where you have some Matrix function
times x tilde
plus b of x times U tilde
and you can solve a state what's called
a state dependent ricotti equation and
do feedback in a non-linear manner using
linear like tools and it works uh pretty
well in practice
there's some I think there's some
analogy with what we talked about before
with the certificate-based feedback with
contraction Theory so
um
CCM based or contraction theory-based
feedback you as long as you have a
decreased condition satisfied you're
guaranteed to be exponentially stable
it's a guarantee
where this bottom line here is just a
decreased condition I've written out for
the closed loop system with some
controller pi and without getting you
don't have to sort of know every term in
here but the critical thing is to notice
that it depends on
State and input samples it depends on
your Dynamics a controller and a metric
so this you know three different things
you're learning Dynamics controller and
some certificate function it's a lot of
things to try and fit to data
in contrast this ricotti equation based
feedback it's a heuristic it's locally
optimal it's no guarantees on
stabilizability but it does work well in
practice
and you what you're doing is you're only
depending on some factories form the
Dynamics and then you're doing ricotti
equation based control you're not
learning a separate certificate function
you're not learning a separate
controller the the structure the
Dynamics yields your controller design
so I think so what prior work has done
is they've what they've tried to do is
let's try and let's take this regression
loss let's take this certificate
decrease condition turn it into an
auxiliary loss term and try and fit all
these functions to data at the same time
what we propose is
try to extract the structure out of the
Dynamics just learn the Dynamics and the
structure that enables record equation
based control
with an auxiliary loss that sort of
ensures that these factorizations are um
are valid or are consistent
and so what we're learning here is the
Dynamics and factorizations of the
Dynamics
so instead learn that in it focus on
learning Dynamics and some details about
them and do ricotti equation based
control
so in a sense that you're learning less
but the hope is that it still yields an
effective controller
so this is precisely what we did so we
did in simulation we did this planar
quad example we wanted to track this
double Loop trajectory
and going from left to right what we've
done is it's an increase in the data set
size so we're going to start we're going
to look at how much data do we need for
each different type of method to do well
and on the bottom I'm going to plot the
the closed loop trajectory error
so this is a baseline linearization
based lqr so linearizes around your
current Point solver a quad equation and
apply that control
okay so this is the Oracle so to speak
with the known Dynamics
it does pretty well
um
then we did so this method is basically
fit your Dynamics to data just do naive
regression and do linearization based
lqr on that model
and we find it takes a while before it
starts to do well
we then tried out the CCM base the
basically the the idea of learning
Dynamics controller and certificate and
again also struggles a bit to get up to
the same level of performance
we do our method it does really well
even for a low amount of data this is
purely learning the Dynamics and all at
the same time learning some structural
Dynamics to enable
non-linear lqr like control
so we found it's it's very it enables
very data efficient learning
and in this plots we did it through two
different systems and along the x-axis
is again the data set size and on the
right on the upper vertical axis is sort
of RMS trajectory error and we've taken
sort of multiple random seeds and
figured out the distribution in this
these results and we get similar case
where as you increase the amount of data
you could do better but our method in
green already does really well for low
amounts of data and in fact for enough
data it beats out the oracle
and the key thing here is to remember
that we're learning a controller that's
inherently non-linear while the Oracle
is using a linearization-based control
so remember I said that non-linear base
control we hope it does better than
linearization based control and it does
in a lot of cases so we can find even
now we're learning the Dynamics we still
get that happening
so overall what we've seen is that
enforcing this factorized structure
enables a type of control and
outperforms is more sample efficient
than naive and certificate-based methods
I've got a couple minutes and I'll sort
of I might have to go a little fast this
next section
forgive me but we'll move into sort of
the final section which should be more
about the Adaptive than online setting
so last two we're about learning a model
offline and deploying it online
but like I said often we're pretty good
at driving at least some basic model by
hand
and then maybe what we want to do is um
so fine tune it online so
here we have a typical feedback loop
from state to controller to system and
then you have your feedback Arrow going
backwards taking the state back to the
input to the controller for an arm it
could be desired your state is or
position velocity or joints
um
and usually in a controller like I said
we're relying on some knowledge of the
system and the system model that we're
using consists of maybe two things both
structure and parameters structure could
be the fact that Force equals mass times
acceleration
parameters are maybe the mass and shape
of your payload that you maybe those are
uncertain especially if you're doing
pick and place operations your mass
of your end effector and the inertia
that you're dealing with are changing
um so what adaptive control does is it
says okay well maybe we don't know the
value of these parameters but we
maintain estimates and try and change
them on online and learn them online
and what's interesting is that a
defining characteristic of adaptive
control is that it can guarantee
tracking convergence
but parameter convergence is only
guaranteed as a secondary result
so you know parameters don't have to
converge but you'll get tracking
convergence
a little odd
the theory works
so the idea is that it this is sort of
naturally a a form of control oriented
learning or adapting parameters on a
need to know basis for control
so the tricky part is maybe we don't
know this structure so maybe for an arm
we can write it
but for a drone in wind conditions it's
hard maybe to derive the interaction
with the Drone and aerodynamic forces
so the idea is that what we propose a do
is learn this model a model for these
forces and the Adaptive part is maybe
just the last layer of this deep model
that we want to learn
and I think I'm running out of time but
the idea is that if we have data from a
drone from multiple different days when
we're flying it or multiple different
conditions that we fly it in we can
treat each one as a task if we use the
meta learning vernacular
and the idea is that the the Dynamics
the forcing dynamics that we don't know
are different for each condition
the idea of meta learning is learn some
shared structure some shared features
for each of these different conditions
and adapt some parameters online that
are specific to the task
so this is the concept of meta learning
and what prior work has done is done
this with a regression objective
basically differentiating through least
squares or a data fit objective and we
do it instead with
a
a control objective so we actually
simulate the system
and then back propagate through a
simulate closed loop simulation instead
of just back propagating through at
least scores objective
and I'll skip through
but it turns out so our method or sorry
the baselines are in orange and green
and our method is in blue so you can see
a drastic difference of performance
there
I apologize for rushing at the end but
uh I'll turn it over to questions I
guess now
so if you have any questions including
in the last part go for it
[Applause]
yes yeah
very interesting talk I was just
wondering
um are you testing on like quadcopters
throughout and is it like dependent on
how linear the Dynamics of the Drone is
the results you're showing here
yeah so it's on a quadrupt like for this
project it was just the the one system
on the previous product the middle
project I don't know which project do
you mean specifically just in general in
gen I'm just seeing always the picture
of the the Drone I was just wondering
how like if you had done this on the
helicopter for example how well would
they transfer I think that method is
pretty
um agnostic to the system if you look
previously
we did it in two different systems where
so the difference between some of the
baselines was not so drastic for this
system because it was closer to being
linear yeah well this one was a lot
higher more highly non-linear and
non-minimental phase so they're they're
the diff the Delta between our method
and baselines increases when with a
nonlinearity okay very cool yep awesome
talk Spencer that was really cool
um I was just wondering I might have
missed this but in the beginning when
you're you're regressing over models F
to learn is there a certain a priori
structure you impose on that class of
functions the first project yes yes yeah
so the first one is control affine f of
x plus b of x times U
um
there are there's also some with
contraction Theory there are some
assumptions about the system that you
would
that make it simpler to apply these
um
inequality conditions to construct them
one of which is some sparsity in that b
of X
which for example from mechanical
systems we hope that we can divide
our actuated degrees of freedom and are
unactuated degrees of freedom and it
comes up with some sparsity and B of x
the way awake there's one assumption
involving that that we make to simplify
the construction of these conditions
okay so so I guess you have to have some
notion of what the actual state of the
system is before you begin with this
yeah um so discovering a state is is not
what we do okay yeah gotcha all right
sounds good
no I just have my own questions
um I was wondering when you learn
Dynamics and you constrain them to be
controllable do you have any insights on
what would happen if the Dynamics that
you're trying to learn are not actually
controllable or maybe there is some
subset of the states that are
controllable and some that are
uncontrolled are there ways to extend
your methods to those settings or what
do you think would happen when you try
that I think you would have to you have
to find some way of dividing those
things out I mean in linear systems like
I'm just spitballing ideas now at this
point the linear systems you can look at
there's ideas like common decomposition
where you can break down the
controllable States from the
uncontrollable States so you could look
at imposing that kind of structure I
think much like in model order reduction
you'd have to maybe specify how many
states are uncontrollable like a much
like picking the lower dimensional uh
the lower dimension of your model
um
non-linear analogs I'm not sure about
but that's that approach I would go with
something like that